alright we're on question on this one
right over here we often hear people say
if you're teaching math in this country
there's no way you haven't heard of
Salman Khan that's a little bit surreal
to me if that's true how does your Khan
Academy model work for less concrete
subjects say creative writing well I
think well it depends where you want to
go on the spectrum into kind of
subjective subjects I think I think if
we go into something like history if if
there are lectures and clearly there are
history lectures I've been I've
experienced many of them we think once
again that those those shouldn't
necessarily happen during class time
that those are better at the student
space at the students time and then if
you get them out of the way using
something like the Khan Academy then you
then class time can have a richer
discussion and on top of that right now
our exercise platform for the math it
generates math problems it's it's harder
for a computer to automatically generate
a history question or even frankly some
types of math questions and so what we
think we can do is probably create a
repository of questions that have
appropriate data with them you know how
hard are they how long does it take
someone to do how relevant are they to a
specific topic and so we can quiz people
on topics like history so that so that
we don't have that yet but that's
something we would like to do in the not
too far future so that someone can with
the lectures get a basic scaffold of
their understanding of history through
through the the videos and they can get
practice so they make sure that they at
least have the basic they you know they
understand when world war one was weird
world war two is what's the differing
the League of Nations and the UN and all
of these type of things and so when they
go to class time if they have access to
a classroom the classroom can be there
for four really rich discussion and the
teacher the professor knows because
they're going to have data based on how
people perform on the Khan Academy what
videos they watch and how they perform
on the on the question is the teacher
will know how prepared the class is for
a richer discussion for something like
creative writing and you know creative
writing is you know and i would put that
probably with you know music composition
and and you know actually you know art
painting art or studio art you know
things that are purely creative i would
say that
if there are any lectures so if there's
if right now in a creative writing class
there are teachers giving basic lectures
on just things to think about we think
that those things can be taken out of
class time that those can be done in a
video it's it's I'm probably not the
right person to do it but we'll be able
to find people who can do those those
creative writing lectures and also even
in creative writing there are there is a
basic skill set that you want to have in
order to be a respectable creative
writer you basic grammar or vocabulary
you know looking doing a critical
analysis of other writing so some of
that can be done in a video form factor
what we everything we want to do is to
enable the class time to be all about
writing and getting feedback and getting
assessment and and critically analyzing
other people's work so it's actively
kind of its activity-based work as
opposed to as opposed to just just
listening to a lecture creative writing
we don't have any other that you know I
can imagine there will probably be some
videos eventually for maybe writing
generally grammar vocabulary of some
forms of you know critical analysis what
what I think we could do eventually for
critical writing and once again this is
completely on the drawing board and
something we won't be able to get to for
the near term but I think you can do a a
model where Khan Academy has kind of
creative writing projects and students
right creative you know they write
essays and they write short stories and
they write poetry and members of the
Khan Academy community can can give them
feedback on how they did and they can
assess how how how good the writing was
and and the students themselves will
assess other people's writing and I
think if we can do something like that
once again will become a tool where we
can we can automate a lot of the the
overhead of trying to coordinate who's
going to assess whom's work and and all
of the rest and then you can once again
use class time and with as much human
interaction as possible so I don't want
to claim that we've solved that problem
but I suspect that there are ways you
know one thing I want to make clear in
this interview is that we aren't married
to a
a particular a particular type of
technology we aren't saying that it has
to be a black background with Sal
scrawling in in pastel colors and and
just talking about a subject we aren't
married to the idea that you have to
have a knowledge map that structured
that way our number one goal is how can
we make a to dance learning experience
as productive as possible and how can we
make that that scares time with the
teacher with the professor and with the
students peers in that classroom how can
we make that as rich and productive as
possible and so that's what drives all
of our thinking so over time you know I
suspect in 10 years I might not
recognize a lot of what Khan Academy is
but i'll be very excited because it's
going to be empowering a lot of those
basic core principles and we're always
on the lookout for things that can kind
of do that so in something like creative
writing it's true we don't we don't
offer something right now history we do
offer a few a few videos and we'll
probably have a kind of a question bank
in the not too far off future but for
creative writing we want to explore that
space and we want we do eventually want
to empower even the creative writing
class rooms next question you said that
most educational software loses sight of
the end user what should the people in
charge of purchasing these materials
understand about them you know it's a
very simple idea i would i would say if
you are in a decision-making role
purchasing materials and this is true
whether you're in education or anything
don't just don't just be impressed by
the Polish of what the sales person
tells you or the fact that other
districts are doing it or when you flip
through the book it seems to have fancy
graphics and it seems to be expensive in
it you know it seems to meet all of the
state standards I think the best thing
that anyone can do is say you know what
let me take out this book and let me
take out this piece of software and let
me try to learn from it let me try to
you know pick a subject that if you're
the if you're the if you're the the
school's principal or the district
superintendent or whoever you are say
you know I'm a little rusty on systems
of equations let me see if I can learn
systems of equations from this book and
let me see if it's really that
dramatically different than the older
textbook or if it's drew the software is
dramatically different than the textbook
and that's really the best way to see if
it's if it's effective in fact i think
that's that's true about
assessing anything I mean I think all of
us have experienced that sometimes even
you know amongst teachers there there
could be you know a very flashy
presentation and not just teachers
videos even there could be a very flashy
presentation and if you look at it
superficially you say oh my god this
this is this is going to be good
instruction but you're not actually
trying to learn from or that thing might
not actually teach you it might the the
the more basic lecture or the more basic
video oftentimes might do a better job
at teaching you so the the real way to
the real way to assess something is to
actually try to learn from and I'm not
saying that flashy is necessarily bad
i'm just saying that flashy is not
necessarily good it's just a lot of us
it's easier to assess something very
quickly saying oh look that pot looks
polished that looks like there's a lot
of money spent into it it must be good
but the reality is try to actually learn
from it and you'll find that some of the
more basic things can often do better so
so I'd encourage I did encourage you
know and I encourage anyone who's anna
looking at anything like that is to
question to question what their
assumptions that does that you know does
a calculus textbook have to have a
thousand pages in it it doesn't have
even be a hardcover book why don't you
separate it into multiple chapters I
mean all of these questions I think you
know people I mean they all boil down to
the basic principle that you should just
try to learn from that content
yourselves and if and if you learn
better from that content it's like and
you find that content engaging and you
find it something that you can engage
with it's likely the students will be
able to and if and if you can't and if
it's just flashy and looks polished then
it's likely that the students won't
won't be able to either next question
next question at the heart of the Khan
Academy's philosophy is the importance
of enabling students to learn at their
own pace what happens when these
students enter the workforce do they
work perform surgery try case analyze
data or even teach at their own pace yes
you know I think the at your own faces
exactly is exactly what happens in the
real world you know every every job i've
been at there was no 30-person classroom
where i had to you know where everyone
was moved ahead at the same time it was
first of all it was a lot of learning on
your own you had to figure out what
needs to be learned
was you know there wasn't anyone holding
your hand and and you had to learn your
own face you work at a firm you have to
kind of figure out what's important and
then you have to go usually it most
firms figure out you know ask the right
questions from the right people and and
then proceed at your own pace and so you
actually see that in you that is
actually the reality in in in most in
most fields you you learn from
experience and from your own kind of
inquiry and and that tends to happen at
at your own base that no one forces you
along until until you really have have
and you don't force yourself along until
you've mastered something so yes I
actually think that's why so many
students right now suffer when they go
into the work force is that they're so
used to being kind of shepherded along
at kind of as a cohort that all of a
sudden when they're thrown into the work
environment and all of a sudden you have
to decide when it's time to ask the boss
for promotion you have to decide when
you think you're ready to go back to
grad school you have to decide when you
think you're you know you're ready to
start your own business if some people
struggle when they're you know they're
not being told now you're going to go to
12th grade now you're going to go to
college and and so I think that's that's
an added benefit when you when you give
people at a young age if you give them
control of their learning if you make
them self-directed that's that's a skill
that's just going to translate really
well and really empower them once once
they enter the workforce